wow the statistic says that by 2040 or
50 of all high school graduates will be
in africa so wow that yeah we have the
opposite of what the rest of the world
has with an aging population we have an
increasingly young population
and it's and it's getting younger and
younger and so
the future of africa is huge and bright
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today i am with olodosu tejibo the
co-founder and ceo of analog teams
following all adosu's studies and
information systems at the university of
maryland baltimore county olodosu went
to develop the tech hardware company
teibotek he empowers fellow
entrepreneurs through angel investing an
act that has connected him with black
owned businesses such as ferritry and
the urban planning growth and
sustainability initiative he believes
that consistency and excellent delivery
are the mark of greatness that
philosophy applies to his vision for
analog
[Music]
i'm excited to to hear about your
journey your mission and and your work
through analog teams and you know the
world is changing and technology and you
know is definitely you know disrupting
so many different industries but it's
also disrupting the way that the world
works together and definitely still some
disparities on opportunities in in this
tech field and it almost feels like
sometimes we're creating larger gaps
then then we're then we're closing them
down through tech but but your sort of
mission is to do exactly the opposite
and so i'm excited to hear a little bit
about your own journey what analog teams
is all about so uh oladosu tell me a
little bit about sort of what what
mission you're on and what is sort of
your your passion these days
yeah so uh if i were to speak personally
i would say that i'm on a mission to
inspire a generation of people to do
their best work uh but at analog we talk
about um our mission being to cultivate
and advance people and their talents um
because our mission is about the people
less about the you know trying to
accomplish a specific uh you know
monetary goal or
the outcome is about the people that
come into analog uh and just like you
mentioned that as much as tech is giving
us it is also creating a large disparity
uh between different groups of people
that's actually why we set out to start
analog uh my co-founder maisha and i as
well as our co-founder yao uh we were
all in uh
the tech field
i myself and my issue were gdit general
dynamics
and
we decided that we could create a
culture and a place that
people can do their best work but an
environment that's extremely inclusive
and that's where we believe that people
actually are able to operate their best
from so um that's why we set out for
analog uh what we do we're recruiters
and software developers so one side of
the house handles recruiting for a lot
of startups and and some large uh tech
companies here in the states and then
the other side does software development
for some startups as well
fantastic okay sounds great and so
sort of taking me back a little bit to
the underlying pain point and pain me a
picture of of the world that we're in
that that brings this to life you know
the sort of the need for analog teams
yeah um
it's just the the the opportunities and
technology right um i think that as we
continue to uh uh grow as tech continues
to move forward as ai and the the um
ai comes into into play and continues to
grow um not having enough
underrepresented individuals
specifically black individuals in the
room in technology um making decisions
being a part of the solution uh can be
problematic over a long period of time
and so
just having analog teams where we have
uh top talent top black individuals from
all parts of the world uh delivering at
a high level in gaining access into tech
that may have never gained that access
before um where we're essentially
creating a pool of of candidates that
can go anywhere else in the world and
succeed and so that's really the
importance of analog is having this
place where again as i mentioned people
can do their best work which puts them
in position to have a phenomenal career
now you're operating sort of uh
geography based right so you have active
presence in in africa and working with
individuals there how does sort of the
operation of this organization look like
yeah so we are about 40 individuals
globally um
we're in um
here in the us i believe we're about
five or six and then we're
there's kenya south africa ghana
um zimbabwe
we also have a
a member in um
uh the netherlands as well and then one
in the uk so
we have quite a qua uh um in london but
we have quite a large footprint and
people in very many different countries
cities um etc and so we always talk
about uh
the importance of everyone coming
together for a single value system uh
since we have so many different cultures
it believes uh making sure that we're
all there for that same mission uh to in
our value sets of trust uh passion
accountability and consistency
and about transparency in our uh
community so anytime you meet someone
from analog is actually something that
people often say is that you meet some
of the greatest people that you've ever
met before like you'll feel really at
home
um really friendly everyone really cares
about what they're doing and are super
passionate
awesome tell me a little bit about more
about your own journey sort of leading
up to analog what sort of prompted you
sort of on this entrepreneurial journey
your own background
yeah so um once graduating i graduated
from university of maryland baltimore
county and once i graduated i went as
mentioned to general dynamics it was
actually my first position out of
university
and i just realized that as i climbed
the ladder as i um continued to improve
what i'm doing in my own skill set there
will be less and less people such as
myself that looked like me in the
industry and what i continued to build
uh just a lot of the political climate
things that were happening in the world
kind of led me into
fully taking on the path of my own so
when i left general dynamics instead of
taking another job um i actually started
selling computers and so uh once i
started selling high-end computers to uh
to like governments and entities in
nigeria have a strong connection there
and so um we're building building that
out that was just giving me enough
revenue i was calling my cash cow in
order to actually take the time and
build analog so it actually took us
three years of planning uh we went to
nigeria i stayed in nigeria for a year
ghana for a year um i'm sorry for
someone who's once kenya for a year my
co-founder went to ethiopia ghana um
togo
and uh we actually just went really deep
as far as understanding and building
roots into the communities and countries
understanding the cultures that we
connect with and so that while i was
selling computers i was just building
this entity and then
about two years ago we really hit the
ground running with hiring
picking up projects uh and really
executing the plan that we had put into
place uh beforehand
so right so i mean in the end you
mentioned a lot of the values of of
analog games about transparency and
trust and connectedness
how does this play into sort of an
outsourcing model as you partner with
you know with tech companies and you
provide these services and you and and
you yourself are building sort of a
culture of a company that is working on
a variety of projects how does this how
does this whole thing connect into a
coherent model that scales i believe i
read in an interview game for business
insider about sort of your ambition by
2025 to hire a thousand people uh to be
a part of analog teams so sort of what
is the model that you're building here
yeah so uh
it's great that you bring that up uh
trust is actually one of the things that
we are building into our relationships
with all these entities with the
companies that we work with um a lot of
times they're they've never worked with
people in africa etc so they are a
little bit nervous as far as quality as
far as trust etc uh and so we really
have this open air uh
environment and once we've partnered
with companies they are starting to see
that not only do we
are are we just like great partners to
have we work harder longer faster
and our quality is at the top of the
market and it's something we preach
about is that why is that show up
how do you explain that how do you
explain that that that sort of that
feeling
that that that you provide
yeah um
it it's something you have to experience
but i would just say it's it's
to dumb it down it would be excellent
service right just having partners in
which you work with and
feeling as if they are your
they are in your company and they're
excelling and they might be better than
your team right uh and understand and it
just opens the door every partner we've
worked with has wanted to expand our
footprint in their company especially in
our recruiting services um just
you know meeting with one of one or two
of our recruiters roles that have never
been closed before all of a sudden being
closed all of it you know their their
companies are growing big really quickly
and all of a sudden they're saying well
can we offset our entire recruiting team
to you right can you can you hire
everyone for us um because not only do
we we push p we again it's about people
doing their best work when you create an
environment for people to be passionate
about what they do um to feel like
they're in a place that they can give
their best and receive that in return uh
they they come up and they show up right
work long hours and it's not something
we're afraid of or we push back on we're
we're excited to do the work that we do
so um it's an excitement it's uh um you
know uh passion really i would just call
it passion we're really passionate about
um being able to do hiring people
changing lives on both scales right
we're recruiting we're hiring people
here in companies um and we're watching
them flourish in their company but we're
also hiring more recruiters across the
board and so we're seeing this effect
double on both sides and it's just been
phenomenal to be a part of
fantastic and sort of take me to them to
the messaging sort of on the on the u.s
side so as you're working with companies
sort of what is the positioning of
analog teams in respect to market
opportunities
and development opportunities
how how prominent also is sort of the
the the culture that you're building
here sort of in the messaging
yeah so um
our messaging uh claire in total is just
recruiting partners uh outsource your
recruiting
some people call it recruiting as a
service
uh so it's a very simple methodology if
you're if you want onshore recruiters uh
people in the united states we have a
team of recruiters that can onboard and
embed into your team um and then if
you're okay with offshore and it's a
little bit cheaper price of course just
more affordable for so it really works
for some of those small startups that
don't have the same uh you know funding
that other companies do and then we're
able to scale
when you have a high you know when your
recruiting needs go up when you get that
next funding round you need more
recruiters you're able to utilize your
partners that have been working with you
and then also for this economic downturn
that has happened we've also been able
to work with our team our companies to
pull back their recruiting cert needs as
well so a lot of that messaging just has
to do with being recruiting partners
it's less about us being um an african
you know african focus or or black focus
but more about being the best recruiters
that you can partner with
but and these are the people on analog
teams that you know they're not working
for the companies that they're giving
services to right they're working for
analog teams and then they're providing
services for
the company that that you are working
with right
yes correct however um because of the
way that we structure um our
we have embedded recruiters so they will
essentially work as if they'll have a
company email they'll go to the company
meetings et cetera
but they do have their support in the
background and they do have some
requirements from analog uh and based to
just continue to elevate their skill set
uh people that they can count on etc so
they're embedded into the company
they're a partner they're part of your
company they come to your all hands your
town halls your scrum calls uh but then
they also have some assistance in the
background to make them
just to propel them
so you mentioned that sort of as as
you're building trust with with these
clients
is there
you know different things that you found
that were more helpful in in creating
that trust because at the end you know
they come for a company to come and and
and take on additional services
especially you know that are that are
intimate to their company development
process it's it's not it's not an easy
process i'm sure for any outsourcing
model whether you're you're
african-based or anywhere else in the
world
how how did you find most effective
in creating that trust with clients as
you're providing these services and and
and creating that layer of transparency
that you're describing here because you
know and one it it's great in a
conversation but i imagine sort of as a
ceo or as a development leader you know
i need to really really trust you and
the team in order to to want to work
with this organization and i'm curious
how you're thinking through that as
you're scaling you know your client base
so you have to also scale your ability
to turn transmit that message of trust
yeah absolutely this is the phenomenal
question um i uh we've been lucky so far
uh with our partners the dot connect who
we've worked with they're in rpo and
we've worked behind them and been able
to grow our services uh through them and
it's just been a phenomenal partnership
because they work with so many big names
like you know qualcomm snapchat mission
lane some other startups acorns etc and
so we've been able to find our way into
so many different companies and
situations and get our name out there
specifically having this uh prior
contract which has been phenomenal for
us but as you mentioned uh as we
continue to grow and scale communicating
that has been um what we're working on
and constantly improving uh trying to uh
in
instill that trust even before you have
met us but having uh uh just our track
record and seeing the the success
metrics that we've come uh a lot of
times i may even offer a 30 days uh paid
service where it's like just try
ourselves for 30 days um and you'll see
and usually once our clients have
experienced 30 days of our work they're
begging us like please please stay on
what else can we do what else is great
for us so that's that's been really
helpful as well
is this a sort of
the the connection to to africa tell me
a little bit about that is this sort of
an understanding that you have that
there is sort of this blue ocean of
opportunity that is that is not really
tapped into you know sort of what is the
motivation leading up to this
yeah um
let's say i i actually listened to your
uh your podcast with um adesua uh the
ceo of um
arua capital management and she
mentioned some really
amazing things that i liked uh
just
as you mentioned the grain field of
africa there are
there is a huge lack of investment and
the entire continent all 54 countries
are 1.1 1.3 billion people wow the
statistic says that by 2040 or 2050
50 of all high school graduates will be
in africa so wow that yeah we have the
opposite of what the rest of the world
has with an aging population we have an
increasingly young population
and it's and it's getting younger and
younger and so
the future of africa is huge and bright
however
there becomes a huge problem if
technology if
supply chain management manufacturing
etc do not increase in scale to
accompany all of these new
human beings and so
analog is our first frontier into being
able to one have a huge reach into
africa um hire
many high level individuals most of our
people even though they're recruiters or
software engineers they're actually have
they actually have masters in chemical
engineering we actually have a rocket
scientist a literal rocket scientist who
sends me videos of his rockets he's
built um and on our team and so
uh
being able to cultivate as mentioned and
advance so many individuals gives us a
footprint in africa uh not just for
today but for the next 10 20 50 years
into the future uh and looking at when
we build this company what do we
transform into right
we will of course in order as the
innovator's dilemma says we're going to
have to innovate over and over again and
so we've talked about
you know transcending into manufacturing
into autonomous vehicles electricity uh
so many if different issues that we see
in africa that we will eventually solve
and so right now it's about putting our
feet down in the land and having that
connection with the us uh having been
born here raised here uh and schooled
here
for the us to have people that they can
trust right in africa that's been a huge
conversation is
uh you know the corruption cetera well
you have people who who are you can
touch and feel and actually understand
the lay of the land can take you to
these countries and you can experience
actually the trust and the great culture
that we've built uh and so that's really
the inspiration
and the the thought process of what
we're trying to accomplish now
i love it that that is so cool and i'm
blown away by some of the statistics you
mentioned and it makes it makes perfect
sense
what do you get most excited about in in
your work in your day to day what what
really sort of drives you and excites
you
yeah i i i was so redundant a little bit
but it really is the people uh i work
with the most amazing people in the
world
uh and
they
they've i've grown a million times over
um been blown away by just like the
effort the determination as i mentioned
the passion of of people who really work
hard and in a generation of people who
want to work less and put in less effort
um and yet receive more uh we have a a
group of people who want to put in more
effort uh who want to work the long
hours and put in the time you know
blowing up my phone in the middle of the
night and i'm like i need to sleep um
but i have to i have to continue to push
because they they are so adamant about
achieving our goal and the lives that
we've changed it's just um
it's one of those things that when you
set out to to change lives and and make
an impact when you're actually seeing it
happen and um you know
it stops becoming just your vision and
it's the vision of the people around you
it just becomes one of the most
inspiring things that you can ever be a
part of
i love it i love it uh really i want to
thank you for for coming here um and
it's a it's a pleasure talking to you
about you know something that i honestly
know very little about and that's
exactly why i do this show and then so
i'm definitely gonna have to look into
more about this continent and about
what's happening and and and how do we
how do we bridge this gap because
obviously you know we're constantly
talking about tech shortage around the
world and at the same time people are
complaining about this tech shortage and
lack of resources at the same time we
have all these all these areas which
we're not really tapping into and we're
not really creating these bridges that
are allowing us to to both get better
education and better installments of of
uh you know of technological
infrastructure in these areas at the
same time we're complaining that we
don't have enough in our own geographies
in a world that's totally globalized and
digitized so it's a so i
especially love what you're doing here
thank you again for the inspiration for
the time and for your great work
i look forward to continue being a fan
from the side of analog teams and thank
you again
thank you thank you for having me it's
much appreciated i appreciate it thank
you
[Music]